[Aplausos]
una vez más los colores blanco y rojo de
la oposición inundaron las principales
vías del centro de minsk decenas de
miles de manifestantes se movilizaron
para rechazar la reelección que el
presidente alexander lukashenko obtuvo
el pasado 9 de agosto con más del 80 por
ciento de los votos
desde entonces la ciudadanía exige un
nuevo escrutinio y manifiesta su apoyo a
la líder de la oposición es de plana
tica nos calla desde su exilio en
lituania tica nos calla reclama la
victoria en dichas elecciones
presidenciales después de cinco semanas
de movilización los manifestantes no se
rinden y los estudiantes están en
primera línea
somos la juventud queremos cambio
queremos desarrollo queremos progreso
fue una manifestación bajo estricta
vigilancia la capital está custodiada
por un número importante de policías
antidisturbios incluso se desplegaron
tanques del ejército desde el inicio de
la protesta varias decenas de
manifestantes han sido detenidos
incluyendo periodistas y estudiantes en
redes sociales circularon vídeos de los
múltiples arrestos
y la gente comenzó a correr cerramos la
puerta entonces de 15 a 20 personas con
máscaras llegaron y comenzaron a romper
los vidrios se llevaron a varias
personas
a pesar de la escalada sin precedentes
de las tensiones el presidente
lukashenko en el poder desde hace 26
años excluye cualquier posibilidad de
diálogo argumentando que la movilización
es un complot occidental